allez-y maintenant c'est bon assez
gentil bas autour de chacun des tout
madame façon que l'argument pouget liste
de dire papa de mises sont tes soins de
médecins ces débits on peut très bien
compétent dans ce domaine si c'est
pareil alors clamé ce qu'est ce qui fait
la force du problème surtout extrêmement
premier numéro
vincent
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas trop
bon là on arrive aux probables away là
on a un gros gros gros gros gros soucis
là mais à huy ah oui quand-même un le
gagner pâle avec le dos de la cuillère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
juste pour les français qui nous
regardent le projet posait c'était
d'aller dans le sens que vous m'avez
indiqué capillairement hier mais c'est
peut-être pas tout à fait ça oui alors
vous êtes passés d'eads s'est passé
d'eddy mitchell à pierre bachelet petit
jolie fille elle adore franchement je
l'attends
je ne vais pas vous parler je vous
engage à tapas y est qui
randonnée rimont et moi j'essaie de
faire tous les métiers nos entreprises
c'est bien mais le problème ici ce qu on
vous connaît vraiment vous a reconnu
alors j'avais un peu envie de venir
prendre les fiches
ah ouais pas mal de faire un peu
[Applaudissements]
ouais
système tant qu'on est dégueulasse c'est
normal qu'on tombe des chouettes mais
chômage il a raison de tenter à la voilà
il va se baisser
gilles je vous le jure qu'il ya un truc
on dirait un peu un chanteur d'indochine
mais 13 heures on ira un peu les beatles
on dirait on allait les beatles joie des
skittles mais c'est sympa vous allez
rester comme ça toutes les missions
ah ben oui à mon père faisait un peu la
même fougue tous les bus toujours semblé
plus en plus les de la morinie bosque et
les vernets sans rigoler 1
la seule chaîne où le prg à côte le
patron vient pourrir un programme
efficace je vous jure alors pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent c'est le grand
patron a pu servir au dessus de lui
aller banias les avions mais c'est vrai
et le gars me jette mais dit sur l'âge
on va dire la tête bien même comment je
vais me venger la vie là de la ferme et
on tombe malade avec da [ __ ] pour aller
au bureau des amis noirs ont fait toute
la déco